foreign
let's go to Hope in Columbus what's up
hope
hi um how are you today I'm fantastic
how about you
a little nervous but hey I'm nervous too
listen I've just train wrecked this show
starting off this morning so you can't
be any worse than I was
so what's up
um okay so I am I'm really struggling to
be attracted to my husband a particular
particularly during intimacy okay um I
think part of it is I'm struggling with
some hormonal imbalances since being
postpartum and then also we have some
other sexual baggage that just I can't
seem to let go of tell me about it
um so
uh my husband I'm a Christian and so is
my husband and he um he was with someone
else before we were married and we've
been married three years and I just
still struggle uh thinking about that
when we're together
was that did you struggle with that
before you were married
I did yes did you struggle with that
before you had kids or is this something
new
um it's kind of off and on I it was a
really big struggle the first year or
two of our marriage and I kind of
I thought I had like defeated it but I
think I just kind of numbed out my
feelings to it
why do you think this is something you
need to go to war with
or let me ask you in a different way
uh the defeat language is is concerning
because it's a fight you're not gonna
win because it's not a fight
um
what is it about you
that you feel like isn't enough
because it feels like it's about your
husband's past and this and that and
he's been with other people and all that
this is about you feeling like you're
not enough
tell me about that yeah I'm not sure I'm
not sure to answer that
am I off am I wrong
no I wouldn't say you're wrong
that's been with you for a long time huh
yeah I think so
do you know where that comes from
I think it's from my mom
tell me about that
um she
I just think she would say to me as a
kid like one particular that just is
stuck in my mind is
um she she asked me she's like don't you
just wish that don't you wish you had
these like feminine features and you
were more beautiful and you just
you're dude you're very good at
um
christianese
at sugarcoating things be very direct
what'd your mom tell you
she told me I wasn't pretty pretty much
it would be really cool if your body
looked different
yeah yeah
and so every time you stand before your
husband you think I can't be as
attractive as
the other girl was five or six or seven
years ago
and he must be yeah
he must be
he's picturing her thinking of her
instead is he
no no no no because he has a naked woman
right in front of him right
uh I'm sorry your mom told you that
she shouldn't have told you that
that was her projecting her own
insecurities onto you
and you were her little girl and you
didn't deserve that
and for all of us parents out there this
is what this looks like 5 or 10 or 15 or
20 years later when we put our
insecurities on our kids
then they stand before
the person they love
and they say this is all of me
and that person says I'm all in and we
go no you're not
because even even our parents weren't
all in right
um
um
have you told your husband about this
does he know um I tried I tried to talk
to him about the like how I'm struggling
like with intimacy a couple months ago
but I don't think he knew how big of a
deal it is because I like I still try to
be with him but for me it's just not
like
I don't feel as connected to him as I
should I feel like I should be able to
okay
um I want to back out of the whole
conversation there's a weird thing that
happens with our brains and our brains
are story making machines
and so here's a good example uh it's
like a simple example I can have a
morning where I have my morning coffee
at my house which is just part of my
routine and then this morning I'll use
this morning it's a great example
um I have my morning coffee at my house
which is a lot
um and then I went to breakfast I go to
breakfast every morning once a week in
the mornings with my son and I had a
whole bunch more coffee there and then I
get here and somebody had brought me
like hey we know you like this
sugar-free vanilla floofy thing we got I
got you on
so suddenly I have had 18 cups of coffee
in the single morning and my body is
jittered out and my brain thinks
I've got anxiety issues
my brain begins looking for stories that
back up why my body is is rattling the
way it is
and it must be because of this and oh
yeah because of this and I happen to
walk by
um you know I work in at Ramsey
Solutions I work at a big Media company
and there's there's walls of banks of
different news shows on and
um oh it's because like then my heart
starts beating a little bit faster so
it's my body it's my mind
in search of a story that backs up how I
what my body's doing does that make
sense
and so I can imagine a scenario where
you still struggle with feeling secure
in your body I get that totally totally
and I can also Imagine you've just had
is this your first kid
yeah yeah just had your first baby so
your husband is married to a completely
different woman right now and you're
married to a completely different man
right now and you'll probably haven't
had that conversation yet and sex used
to be look like X and Y and Z and now
everybody's tired everybody's buzzing
around everybody
misjudged how many diapers have to be
changed in a certain day
nobody feels sexy when they're getting
peed on and there's poop under their
nails and when we have to take the trash
like Everything's changed
and then you start feeling like we're
having sex and it doesn't feel as good
as it did or feels different or he's
being a little bit weird or a little bit
different
and now the story machine cranks up to
try to backfill why our bodies feel how
our bodies feel do you see what I'm
saying
yeah and then it starts to magnify
itself and so what I want to do is be
really open and vulnerable and vocal
about what's actually happening not the
stories that we're creating about what's
happening
here's what that means hey honey sex
feels different now
and by the way it won't forever but it
does right now
does it feel different for you I feel
your body is different right now
or I feel you're not as engaged in it or
I'm having trouble staying engaged in it
and this can lead to an adventure of
I'll figure out a way to help you be
engaged you tell me you see I'm saying
now it can be a whole adventure of y'all
discovering each other further or it can
be the thing that shuts everything down
you see what I'm saying yeah when sex is
wrapped up in shame
and when you have self-doubt when he's
got self-doubt when he doesn't know what
to say or how to say it you don't know
what how to tell them what you need and
what you're like when we get into this
back and forth shame-filled world
the awkwardness can lead us to you know
what I'm I'm good I I don't want to
enter into that awkward space so I'm
just going to stay by myself and now the
story machine just loses its mind okay
here's the here's your new assignment
are you ready
mm-hmm
all right let me just pause there tell
me what you're feeling or thinking as
I'm talking you can and you can say dude
you're full of crap or
um tell me what you're thinking
um I'm still just not sure like how to
tell so how to express that to my
husband because
I don't I don't want to like destroy his
confidence because he's you know he he's
lost a lot of weight recently like 70
pounds and he's the most attractive he's
ever been to me and then as soon as it
gets like to the time for intimacy it
just like
I I struggle with that
are
can I say something mean
yeah no it's not mean it's just direct
is that cool
yeah he knows you're not enjoying
yourself
I know he's been asked
obviously yes
that's the secrets are destroying your
relationship far more than being honest
would
and that's what I'm saying I don't think
this has to do with his appearance I
don't think this has to do with his past
I think this has to do with you not
feeling like you're worthy of a guy that
looks as good as he does right now
I think you're
you're bringing a story to the table
that you're not enough you're he just he
accepted you but man he wish he could
have so and so and so and so and so and
so and then your mind goes Off to the
Races
at some point you have to decide
I am not going to engage in those
thoughts when that thought lightning
bolts in your mind you're gonna
literally say out loud nope not doing
that
and you're going to have some other
thoughts to backfill it some really
romantic intimate times y'all were
together or times y'all laughed really
hard until you almost threw up together
I don't think it's I don't think it's
worth your energy to try to mine to go
down a rabbit hole every time you're in
the middle of having sex and be like
okay why I'm not really
into this like I think why that's the
worst the worst time to be thinking
through those kind of things right
because then you're not present in that
moment
um I want you to pick up a book called
Come As You Are by Emily nagotsky and
we'll link to it in the show notes Here
um it's the greatest
book on female sexuality I've ever read
it's not a faith-based book by any means
okay
um but she is a teacher and the book is
easy to read and I have had very very
few people very few people not come back
and say that book changed my life it's
incredible and he might want to read it
too here's the Crux of it and the reason
I love it she takes away the idea of sex
drive she changes the picture of what
attraction is and she creates a
compelling case for sexuality especially
in like a marriage relationship being in
very much Environmental
there's a it's not a sex drive like he's
got more of it I've got less of it
sometimes I it's a series of offs and
ons
okay and the goal for each couple is to
figure out how can we turn on as many
ons in this environment and turn off as
many offs
especially after you just had a baby
because everything is different now
does that make sense
yeah yeah so here's an example in my
house I've told us on the show before I
thought that
um like in my house
for years the kitchen had to be clean
before we we went back and and to the in
the in the back room and I thought for
years
my wife was putting our time together
second to a clean to having the dishes
out of the sink
and I started taking it personal
like seriously like I'm less like look
at this I'm a smoke show all right I I
I've got to be more attractive than a
and then like seven dishes in the sink
and in her mind she had a picture of the
way a house is supposed to look so that
she had accomplished her job
and she had created a story that
if this isn't done then I'm not doing my
job and if I haven't done my job I can't
relax and enjoy myself
and so what we were doing is we had two
stories going about the dishes that
neither of them were truthful or
accurate but there were stories we were
bringing to the table ended up being a
mess and so finally when we sat down
because we had to
we neglected these conversations our
whole marriage we had to start having
these hard conversations or our marriage
wasn't going to make it
we started talking about the series of
offs and ons
and then it was like I can't move
forward because of the way I feel about
me if I haven't uh if there's dishes in
the sink
and for me it was like oh this has
nothing to do with me this has to do
with the fact that this is a story she
tells about herself I'm gonna get all
the dishes out of the sink all the time
see what I'm saying and now I'm about
something completely different
um oh you need me to text you in the
morning you want me to tell you this
thing you want me to remind you of dude
I can do that that's simple that's
taking another off off the table and
turning another switch on and so it
became a fun fun filled Adventure
figuring out what are all the odds and
what are all the offs and ons and offs
like are not all very few of them are
sexual most of them are creating an
environment it's why you can go to a
hotel
and just
called cause the wallpaper to peel
itself off right because you're like
getting after it and then you come back
home and you're in a different
environment and everything's like whoosh
it's all gone right and so it's you
mining
your environment you deciding I'm not
gonna have these thoughts about his old
girlfriends or his old ex-wife or
whatever I'm not gonna I'm not going
there in my head that's a choice and
over time your brain will quit
defaulting to that that is your brain
trying to come up with a story
that is going to justify you not being
enough for him and by the way hope he
chose you you're enough
do you believe that
kinda okay
today is going to be the first day you
tell the full truth okay
you're not gonna destroy him you're
gonna tell him you love him you can tell
him he looks really good and you're
going to tell him
three months after having a baby I'm
struggling with sex and I'm struggling
with how it feels and when it doesn't
feel like I thought it was going to or
the whole environment isn't like what I
thought then I start cranking up stories
like you're thinking about your ex like
that I'm not enough that my mom told me
my body doesn't look good and you
probably think like she does put all
those things out there
do you trust him enough to hold those
things with you
oh yeah okay
okay and maybe you write yourself a
letter write him a letter and read it to
him so that you don't um get nervous or
don't get jittery or don't miss those
things
um and then you guys get to do the
funnest thing in the entire world
as you get to practice
you get to practice what intimacy is
going to look like in this new season
with the new baby you're going to
practice what intimacy looks like where
you start feeling confident in your own
body and confident in the fact that he
picked you
he picked you as the one person he's
going to be intimate with for the rest
of his life he chose you
and you all get to figure out together
what offs and ons in your home mean
and dude there's a lot of things to
practice you can practice free throws
you can practice you know I don't know
cutting boards in your backyard with
your new circular saw there's few things
on earth better
than practicing
how we're going to be more intimate
together and how we're both going to
love sex more over time
then I get much better than that
but that starts with vulnerability and
it starts with you being honest and that
hope
starts today